sexual misconduct was a big theme of
last night's Golden Globes celebrities
dressed in all black flooded the red
carpet in protest Meryl Streep Emma
Watson and Michelle Williams took
prominent activists for gender and
racial equality as their guests to stand
in solidarity with the times up movement
16 minutes special contributor Oprah
Winfrey became the first black woman to
receive the Cecil B deMille Award for
lifetime achievement she delivered an
inspiring message to young girls that a
new day is on the horizon
[Applause]
it will be because of a lot of
magnificent women many of whom are right
here in this room tonight and some
pretty phenomenal
men fighting hard to make sure that they
become the leaders who take us to the
time when nobody ever has to say me to
again it was an incredible night in CBS
News contributor Jody Cantor is a
reporter for The New York Times and
milena Isaac is a cultural reporter for
The Times they're reporting helped
exposed alleged sexual harassment and
abuse good morning to both of you
Amara Amara that's an extraordinary
night for so many reasons last night
let's talk first about in some ways how
style the idea of wearing all black made
a substantive statement for The Times
that movement I woke up this morning
saying did I have a crazy dream last
night in which the leading actresses of
Hollywood effectively dismantled and
challenged the church the traditions of
the red carpet by saying we're not here
just to be pretty objects we're gonna
talk about substantive issues on the red
carpet and we're gonna use the red
carpet which has traditionally seen
that's pretty retrograde to change the
gender dynamics of Hollywood and Seth
Meyers compared himself to being the
first dog sent up to space male
presenter yeah a lot of anticipation as
to how he would handle last night what
did you think of his performance that's
right I think he made the most of that
anxiety because he addressed the
elephant in the room or the elephant not
in the room as he has put it right away
and he made some really cutting jokes
he mentioned Harvey Weinstein he got
booed in the first few minutes of the
show and then he was able to go on and
kind of be the awards host that we might
have expected so I think anybody who's
you know involved in the Oscars telecast
was watching that closely and they
probably breathed a sigh of relief
afterwards Harvey Weinstein was the
Awards guy right I mean always whether
it was the Globes the Oscars that he was
like a singular focus almost on it and
so to see this change pretty remarkable
Joey this is the world that he
constructed and he was one of the
architects of the award show circuit as
we know it which is part of what made
last night powerful I think because on
the one hand he kind of hovered in the
room but on the other hand people really
didn't talk about him that much there
was a very strong push on looking
forward looking to the future do we
better and some of these numbers are
still striking I mean we talked about
them last week with you and others I
mean four percent of the directors on
the top grossing films that this country
makes are women only four percent some
of the numbers even Louis
cinematographers I mean I think a lot of
people wonder if if you've seen that
change coming in the future that well
one of the comments of the night came
from Natalie Portman who was announcing
the directing award since she said here
are the all-male directing nominees and
it was a completely factual statement
and yet she was making such a powerful
point about how a woman had not been
included it's subtle but powerful
yeah and milena Oprah Winfrey's speech I
mean she's known for terrific
inspirational speeches but she really
kind of stole the show I mean she was
able to we've sort of a historical
narrative with kind of the changing
times and hope and and her own personal
story yeah absolutely I mean who we all
knew that Oprah could do an inspiring
fiery Rowsey speech but what a great
reminder and I think what she was so
effective at was in uniting the themes
of the night you know some of the
messages that other people spoke about
in their award speeches you know times
up
the fact that this is a moment of
inspiration for women that this could be
a moment of change she kind of brought
all of that together in a really
powerful way and as inspiring as that
was one thing has stuck with me Jodie
that you've said throughout your
incredible reporting I believe it was in
one of the pieces for this show where
you said so many women are coming
forward now because they're afraid that
that window of opportunity to speak out
will close so as inspiring as Oprah was
about what what a change this is you
still talk about the window possibly
closing well I think what we saw a lot
of the actresses involved in The Times
up campaign doing last night was trying
to make that window bigger and part of
what was notable was the way they were
trying to expand it to other industries
they were saying this is not just about
us this is about the common experiences
that so many women across the economic
spectrum have here's what's interesting
what do we expect from the Oscars now
it's sort of like your move Oscars right
because the Golden Globes ended up being
very powerful and and yet the Oscars
truly are the kind of bleeding heart of
the film industry so I bet those
organizers are having some pretty
interesting conversations right now the
the one of the lines that that Oprah
used last night she said so I want all
the girls watching here now to know that
a new day is on the horizon what would
that new day include how much inequality
still exists in Hollywood as Jeff was
mentioning those numbers about directors
producers women with leading roles in
movies women with speaking parts in a
movie or even with women are on screen
they often don't speak as much as men or
have as a substantive conversations in
their parts I think you know it takes a
long time to make a movie so of course
it might take a little bit of time to
change for Hollywood but what I think
last night pointed up is that change
needs to happen or people are going to
continue to call it out that it hasn't
the way Natalie Portman did you know of
course there may not be all-female
directing nominees yet but people are
going to shine a light on that fact more
often than in the past what about the
pay gap and in Hollywood how much focus
is going to be on that going forward
well people are just getting a lot more
honest about it Debra Messing on the E
red carpet actually made a statement
about what he pays its female hosts
that's a kind of honesty and frankness
that we have not seen on the red carpet
before it was also one woman speaking up
on behalf of another woman so I thought
it was just an interesting indicator of
where that conversation may go it's
certainly when you talk to the actresses
in private I've had many off-the-record
conversations that I can just generally
summarize and it's a it's a burning
issue among these women the actresses
feel it very acutely and of course you
can't compare the pay scale in Hollywood
to those of everywhere else in America
and all the other industries well thank
you so much for joining us it was a
great night I loved following you tweet
you said you're changing diapers as you
were watching the show as well a true
power woman and mother at that great to
have you thank you thank you